foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
Christians
foreign
[Music]
dude
is it on
yes
okay hi good evening not good morning
how's everyone today
okay okay it doesn't sound like it's on
check check check
that sounds better thank you all right
um I have two announcements for us today
first welcome we're so glad you're here
uh we have a new group starting at the
table it's called Open studio so it's a
really good opportunity we meet twice a
month it's an hour and a half and it's
just to express your creativity so if
you do poetry drawing woodworking
crochet anything like that you're
welcome to join just be creative
together
um I write poetry it's a really great
time to just you know force yourself to
be more into your hobby and just gives
you time to relax and be in communion
with other people
um
it is called Open studio so you can go
to
thetabletx.org meetups for more
information or fill out a card at the
table right out here outside the door
and we'll give you more information next
up is summer Rama now you can register
registration is open
[Music]
it's the the table Kids Day Camp it will
be August 4th which is a Friday and
August 5th right here at the church camp
is for kids who are entering
kindergarten through those who have just
finished sixth grade we also need teens
and adults to volunteer so if you think
you could volunteer at that just two
days lots of fun go ahead and sign up
you can go to the table tx.org or fill
out a card for more information all
right thank you so much
we were just bemoaning that some of us
are out of town for some Aroma the one
time I take a vacation
no vacations guys no just kidding all
right well I'm going to go ahead and
pray and start off our worship if you
guys would like to stand if you're able
no names mentioned that are not able and
may have had serious injuries this week
sorry Karen
the rest of you though if you would like
to stand with us we're going to get
started and this is just a space for all
of us to enter into together there's
this word that has kind of become catchy
in like the worship Community called
Collective
I really do like it I have to admit even
though I want to push back against
Trends but I really like the word
Collective and I think one of the
reasons is because I feel like what's
powerful in worship is regardless of
where you stand whether it's on this
side of the stage or that side of the
stage that we're all entering into this
message together that we can kind of
sing out and take ownership of so I just
want to invite you guys to take
ownership of our worship tonight
um and that may be standing in and
listening or sitting and listening or it
may be speaking those words aloud that
are in the lyrics and taking them in as
as truth as promises as encouragement
for your own life so you guys join us in
this space and um and sing out if you if
you feel comfortable
um I'm going to go ahead and pray and
then we'll get started
Jesus thank you for tonight thank you
for each person that's walked into this
space
I know it takes courage and sometimes
it's uncomfortable but I pray that
tonight as we sing these words together
that they would ring true in our hearts
that they would have meaning in our
lives
that they would take root
and become something that leads us
forward towards you towards your heart
it's in your name that I pray all these
things
amen
[Music]
when darkness tries roll over my bones
when sorrow comes to steal the joy out
[Music]
when Brokenness and pain is all I know
I Won't Be Shaken I Won't Be Shaken
my fear doesn't stand a chance
[Music]
shame no longer has a place to hide
and I am not a captive
[Music]
I'm not afraid to leave my past behind
cause I Won't Be Shaken
I Won't Be Shaken
my fear does insane a chance when I'm
standing your love my fear doesn't stand
a chance when I'm standing in your love
my fear doesn't stand a chance when I
stand In Your Love
[Music]
power that can break off every change
stand a chance
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
kiddos y'all are dismissed obviously
they know what to do so if this is your
first time here our older Elementary's
kids come over to this side and our four
through six year olds come over here
with Jill a special thank you to Devin
and Anna and Whitney and Jill August
um Eve I know all of those people are
working in kids ministry tonight and you
guys what a gift they are to our
community I am so so grateful to have
people who want to love on our kids and
teach them more about the love of God so
special thanks to them
we are going to transition into prayers
of the people if this is your first time
we'll read this prayer aloud together
and then there will be a space for each
of you to
um speak out a name or a situation
that's on your heart tonight and we just
believe that we're holding those
together as a community and up before
God because he is a God who loves us and
is with us and cares about the things
that are on our hearts so um you're
welcome to do that in that space if
you're online you can leave it in the
comments and then we will close out with
another prayer together
read this with me
Jesus for this city of Sachse Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the Widow and orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray to
you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and Hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
even though we know that we're carrying
things into this space that are
sometimes heavy and burdensome
I also believe that there's this
opportunity that we have as followers of
Jesus to lay down the things that are
heavy and pick up his load which is he
says is light
um there's this exchange that happens in
the gospel and you see it through
different parts and stories of scripture
um one of those is in psalm 30.
and David says here Lord and be merciful
to me Lord be my help for you turn my
wailing into dancing you removed my
sackcloth and gave me joy that my heart
may sing your praises and not be silent
Lord my God I will praise you forever
and I love
how David is not ignoring the things
that have been painful he's not pushing
them aside and saying everything is
perfect and everything always goes
though to the perfect will of God we
know that it doesn't we are living in a
broken world and our lives are sometimes
very broken reflections of that
but I do believe that he's offering us
an opportunity to trade in our sorrows
and take up Joy trade in our pain and
take up healing so that's what this song
is kind of talking about and if you guys
want to sing that along with us tonight
and claim that for yourself like we
talked about
um let's try exchanging some of our
heaviness for his life
foreign
[Music]
but it couldn't fill me
a man's empty praise and treasures the
faith are never enough
that you came along
and put me back together
desire is now satisfied hearing your
love
oh there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
nothing is better than you
I'm not afraid
to show you my weakness
failures and flaws you seem them all and
you still call me Fred
cause the god of the mountain
[Music]
he's the god of the valley
and there's not a place your mercy and
Grace won't find me again
feet better than you all there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
nothing is better than you
again oh there's nothing
better than you all there's nothing
nothing is
[Music]
foreign
you'll be beautiful ashes
you'll turn shame into Glory
you're the only one who can you turn
Graves you turn crazy to Garden
[Music]
you turn bones into armies
you turn seasons
one more time
[Music]
you can
oh there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
is better than you let's lift our voices
think that one more time with me there's
nothing better oh there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
nothing's better than you Lord there's
nothing
nothing is better than you
see that again there's nothing better oh
there's nothing
better than you oh there's nothing
[Music]
is
you turn morning to dancing
you give Beauty
[Music]
oh you turn mountains
you turn season to highways
[Music]
we trust you to do that in our lives
help us to respond to your transforming
love God
[Music]
to the love that you have
much
I don't have much
[Music]
for you
wants to learn
[Music]
much
I don't have much
[Music]
I have a life I'll give to you I have a
life
[Music]
really
I don't have much
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you
I don't have much
I don't have much but I have a heart
that beats for you I have a heart that
beats for you
God would we take the little that we
have to offer
would we lean into your transformation
would we let you do a deep work in our
hearts and in our lives
so that we can live as the people you
created us to be
loved and whole
people of Grace
and peace
people of forgiveness and Reconciliation
god with your power fill our lives
would we let you
take up space in our world
changes for the better
thank you for your unconditional love
and grace
let it guide us forward
in Jesus name
amen
would you guys go ahead and turn to the
people around you make them feel
welcomed and then we'll get started with
our panel
am I still muted am I on
good
yeah
sound the same to myself so I don't know
okay cool hey everyone my name is Miriam
I know what you're all thinking no I am
not Brett but I am
in my word second best thing so so as
Brett mentioned last week I'm sure he
mentioned weeks before
he will take off the month of July kind
of like a mini sabbatical
um like you mentioned last week if
you're a teacher or maybe a healthcare
worker we all know the uh burnout rates
are crazy high so we don't want Brett to
do that we want to give him a little bit
of a break so typically in the month of
July he'll have guest speakers so next
week will be another guest speaker and
so on for the rest of the month so just
want to thank you all for joining uh
thanks for coming to watch my show this
is going to be so good and to our
friends online can't forget about them I
know I have some special friends up in
New York that watch so grateful that
you're all here in person and online
so today what we're focusing on is we're
going to do sort of a panel discussion
we're going to have two people up here
with me I'll be kind of the moderator
and you'll get to hear kind of their
thoughts about this series and um just
how they are impacted and how they are
involved in the lgbtq community because
that's something that this Series has
focused on so we are discussing the end
to that series sad day but Sticks and
Stones rethinking the church's stance on
gender and sexual orientation is my
voice going up and down or is it just me
I don't know oh well I'll go with it so
thank you so I'm good at a lot of things
but not good at memorizing this much
stuff so I'm going to recap what this
series was so for those of you if you
weren't with us or maybe if you forgot
our first week in this series we talked
about really two specific verses that
were in the clobber passages and if you
don't know what the clobber passages are
essentially what it is is it's kind of
the verses that people have taken over
the years and used against the lgbtq
community so Brett wanted to unpack a
couple of those
and talk about Scholars who are both
affirming and traditionalists and how
they have kind of moved away from those
texts
um
simply because they are distasteful
pretty much
um the he didn't want to go too deep
into different verses but I suggest that
was a really good message I suggest
watching that one if you missed it um
the second week we shifted into our
focus on Genesis 2 specifically verses
20 through 24 and then that named the
foundation of marriage
um
in the passage as it's not as many
presumed gen between gender differences
but it's actually a shared humanness and
covenantual love third week and in week
three which would have been two weeks
ago we focused on gender gender roles
and that was kind of focused on like the
trans non-binary type community and how
in Matthew 19 12 that there were eunuchs
born that way so he kind of unpacked
that
um
that specific passage and related it to
intersex transgender and non-binary
people today and then last week we
talked about the fact that you can judge
a theology by its fruit I know if you
know when I was here last week or if you
watched online or we were here it was a
pretty heavy passage kind of with all
the statistics that were talked about
and things and kind of really just hit
me deeply and I think in a good way I
think it's good to know what's going on
in our world
um I won't I won't ruin that for you if
you want to go back and watch it I'll
let you do that but the results of that
and how they manifest in people's lives
and then how the traditional theology on
gender and sexual orientation have
essentially led to as Brett put it
terrible horrible no good very bad fruit
which means that it really is time for a
change
um really is a time for a change so
enough of me uh today we're going to
talk we're going to have a panel
discussion so we're going to do two
things we're going to talk about
um we're going to take some time and
base to process what we've learned
throughout this series and then we're
going to hear from two different people
from the table and how they can offer us
maybe riches or advice from their own
perspective of being involved in the
community so I'm going to welcome a
welcome up two people we have Gary and
Carrie and I know I'm gonna just get so
tongue-tied so y'all come up
[Applause]
I think I'll give you that one and then
there's one right there we all can share
are you doing both
there you know
apparently there you go there we go
okay is it this one
oh
you had to slide not push there we go
all right
we good Gary
hopefully
this is uh yeah challenging so anyways
okay well let's already give him a round
of applause we're doing all this I mean
I mean as long as you guys can hear me
yeah I'm gonna stop looking at the
things yeah
yeah volunteering as well
um I know it's going to be a special
moment for or a special time for
everyone so I'm going to give you all
the four give you a couple of minutes
um I want you to just kind of introduce
yourself kind of tell us what brought
you to the table and where you are at in
life right now so I'll pass it over to
you
so my name is Carrie Brandon and
uh how I ended up at the table are from
two of the congregants who aren't here
tonight they named Karen and it was from
when it branched off from New Hope
started with thought and Lucas and then
ended up over here
and are you wanting me to go under the
dove yeah
do what you want yeah you got a couple
minutes to do that to me about
Southern Baptist preachers
and my uncle died of AIDS and it wasn't
even about
me I mean look at me I wore this
intentionally because this is who I am
I'm
a hat girl a Schwartz girl a t-shirt
girl and I love Jesus and now I'm a
chaplain and a peer supporter I'm a
retired firefighter so that's what I do
and I I drink beer and I mean it's just
so when you do that in the faith that I
grew up in not the faith but the the
Baptist Church that I grew up in it
wasn't very well accepted the whole
tomboy theme and not even getting into
this sexuality part so what appealed to
me about the table is that I could just
get to be me
and I I know that this Series has really
been focused on the lgbtq stuff and that
I don't know all the other letters
forgiven but I do honor them
but the whole thing is that I wanted to
find a church where I could just come in
and be with my brothers and sisters in
Christ and just love and worship Jesus
and love on each other
and just be without the hey you're this
you're that the judgment and the
hypocrisy is what drew me to the table
to get away from that not not the
Judgment I said that wrong but you know
what I meant to get away from that was
what drew me to this just so I could
have a place to be me and love and
worship with other people
the same way where they could just be
themselves because that's the way I
picture Heaven is it's going to be like
this we get to I mean if we come
straight out of the ocean in our
swimsuits like we're loving Jesus and
worshiping Jesus or maybe we're sitting
there having a beer or who knows I mean
I just I think that's what God intended
was love
not the hate and the judgment and you've
got to be like this and you've got to
fit in that box so long answer but
that's what brought me to the table I
love what you said about I mean they're
we're very big on the everyone is
welcome but it's different when you feel
it than when you hear it and I love that
that's something you experienced because
it's just you can't replace that within
it where you feel truly welcome and like
you told me earlier I don't have to come
and say hey I Miriam I'm so and so you
know it's I marry him and that's it I
don't have to explain myself to anyone
here and I love that you said that in
this environment to me Fosters
like I I see Miriam as a beautiful
sister I see Gary is a beautiful brother
there's I there doesn't have to be
anything else attached
and that was my issue growing up because
I accepted Christ at five
and growing up with you have to wear a
dress and you have to look like this and
you have to be like this I I wasn't
actually connecting with Christ until I
was 40 is when I discovered the Holy
Spirit and when I just gave it all up
and that's everything from social media
to every and I'm not saying you have to
do that I'm just saying for me that's
what I needed to do to be able to
connect with what I had heard of for
over 40 something years the Holy Spirit
just like oh this is the holy spirit
where you get your arm hairs growing my
hair is growing and it's just like I get
it now that's what draws me to the table
is that experience of just being with
one another
enveloped in love so yeah awesome for
sure awesome thank you so much Carrie
Gary your turn
all right yeah so my name is Gary Miner
um
I was born in the Philippines and I was
brought to United States well around
three
I was raised in California
um let's see I graduated from Plano
Senior High School
back in 91.
and
um what is snickering
um I'm currently living in Wylie Texas
ammo
and um
yeah I am one no no it's not I am one of
the the founding members of the table so
like
um that's what brought me because you
know like helped put it together
um
so
yeah let me also just kind of go a
little bit into my own history
I didn't grow up in church
um
so
yeah so I don't have a lot of that
I guess you could call it baggage what
do you want to call it
um
but I think it was
December 2003 where I came to know
Christ
and
I always one of those people who's like
erratically transformed like you know
turned my life around kind of thing like
I was really into the hedonistic sort of
the dark place of just living my life
for me
um
and
to kind of
sum up where I'm going here is that I
think as I
traveled on my journey of this Christian
walk I became
like I've always I was really released
from a lot of Darkness
but as the the Christian walk went
forward I think I started to kind of
become less
um
like less of a good person and more
judgmental like
it's kind of hard to describe like I
feel like I grew in so many ways as a
person but there was there was this
piece of me that became more and more
religious
um and kind of lost some of my
um
personality and my own my own morals so
to speak as I sort of kind of ingested
what was being taught to me about what
it means to be a Christian
um
kind of that that feeling like
I just I like I got to a point where I
didn't feel like I trusted myself and my
own thoughts and my own emotions so I
just had to like listen to what people
told me to think and believe
um and I was okay with that at the time
because I felt like that was the right
thing to do
um
and so we'll talk more as the questions
go on I don't want to spend too much
time here
um but that's that's about that's a
little bit about me and why I'm at the
table why I'm well I feel like this is
the place to be for me this season
so awesome well I'm excited to hear more
about you know y'all's experience and
stuff as we go into that so let's go
ahead we have a couple of questions
don't know if we're going to get through
all of them but we'll just kind of go
down the list so first thing is
um you know if you saw one message
throughout the series or all of them we
kind of want to just know what was for
you personally the most meaningful or
moving moment that you experience in
this series and y'all can just kind of
answer whenever I'll jump in
um so for me was the
yeah for me it was the the third sermon
where there was a moment where Brett got
obviously emotional
um and he was talking about he was
reading through Isaiah 56.
and so it was that moment of emotion
that it reminded me of all the struggle
um that we went through as a
as a team uh Brett Karen
um
and the rest of our team
the the
what was it called
um the Lucas church family at the time
and all the circles we went through
there
um when we were
let's see when we were faced with the
hidden conservative Line in the Sand
kind of like they were like we're we're
welcoming and affirming but there's a
certain point like once you get up to
that line
then not so much you know
um
you're welcome and wanted until you want
to serve
in some kind in like in kids or on the
worship team the prayer team Etc
um
and so that was just one of those
moments where when I saw that emotion on
Brett's face
it just resonated with me so much
because there was there's history in
that moment
and I just felt like I connected with
Brett in that moment like the where we
were at
um back then and where we are now is
such a huge relief
to not have to operate that way you know
this there's full freedom to be
um Wanted and accepted and right where
you are
um it's not and it's not fake or or
limited you know
anyways so that's my answer for that
that question
so for me
um
the series was very very overwhelming
because I think it's way deeper
than just
lgbtq
I think it has to do with that we're all
made so perfectly and uniquely in God's
image but Society tends to tell us we're
not good enough
and that has been one of my struggles
since I was probably two is not being
worthy and not being good enough so what
struck me about these sermons
is yeah he was able to relate that to
the other issues but
the fact that
we are
involved and we are uniquely Made In His
Image
and I read a verse a couple days ago
and I'm probably going to butcher it
this is this is the part that I get
really not very good at but
regurgitating scripture so the the
premise is that
God was the same yesterday today and
always
and when Brett was preaching that was so
present for me that it was the same guy
back then
the same God that when my parents were
kids when my grandparents were preaching
and for me today and it's going to be
for the future Generations it's the same
God it's the same doubt of love so for
me one thing that was really a struggle
for me is being a female in the ministry
because I can't tell you how many people
look down on that especially coming from
a southern baptist background
it's like nope not gonna do it and I'm
sure you've all heard of the votes that
have happened recently there are
different denominations splitting over
just this very issue among others
but that really struck me Darren Brett's
series of how here's this guy up here
in his cute little rolled up britches
and talking about like how we're all the
same and we're all buffed no matter how
he made us and that's what really struck
me and each one of these sermons was
just so powerful and just reaffirmed and
I love that that's the key word for this
church is affirmed you are affirmed you
are loved
so that's what's up to me so kind of
going off of what both of you said
um you know you had mentioned the prayer
and how that moved you and then also
then when you're a part of another
church and people were able to be
involved to an extent and then you'd
saying you know hearing from Brett you
were loved you were a welcome just
looking at the parallels of that you
know you can hear those words from any
church right but to what extent I always
struggled with hearing I'm loved I'm
welcome but then I in the back of my
mind I'm like but am I really like until
when except for what but here
I mean at least for me like you truly
don't question that you don't feel that
except for blah blah blah you know I
love that you say that because that's so
true and I've been a part of many many
many churches and when I started
rediscovering myself in college I
totally gave up God and religion and
started from Ground Zero
I studied all the you name it Methodist
Presbyterian Buddhist Mormonism Judas
you name it every single thing and I
came back to one thing
that God sent his only son to die on the
cross and he rose again three days later
and we have eternal life and he just
loves me unconditionally that's what I
came back to and what I noticed with all
these other
faiths religions
set of rules sort of you gotta wear
these garments was wait but that doesn't
match up with what I just discovered
over the last seven years and so through
that Journey I've just been trying to
find a church home find a church home
find a church home where I can just be
neat and you were so correct I would sit
in that congregation and I would serve
on the Safety Committee for Ems for with
a gun with whatever it needed to be
to know that I was a part of that church
but yet when it came to oh but wait you
can't wear that hat oh but wait you
can't be like this oh but wait of course
we welcome everybody
but like what you said but when it comes
to this so you take abortion you take
gay marriage and this isn't about
politics this is about
because here's what I believe that the
way God made us we're all going to have
different tapes but that's what makes
the United States of America so
beautiful is that we can have however
God speaks to us
but we can talk about it freely the
problem with a lot of those churches is
you can't talk about it freely
you have to be like this or you cannot
be a part of this congregation you
cannot critique in the bread and the
wine unless you've come up to the front
accepted Christ gone into the baptistry
I just am not like that even though I
grew up like that and I love Jesus I I
just so agree with you with this
environment
it's very open it's very welcome and I
think or my hope for the growth of this
is that it's a space where people who
aren't familiar with this environment
feel safe enough to come up and say wait
I'm not getting it because this is what
I was taught so can you teach me the
other side or talk to me about the other
side maybe it works for them maybe it
doesn't
but this is how we grow and this is how
we spread love and the love of Jesus is
being like this being able to be
ourselves sorry no this is Hey listen
I'm just asking questions this is all
about y'all
um I don't mean to mess with your notes
but I'm going to skip around on
questions just be prepared so I I wanna
no no I wanna I wanna get to this
question for sake of time but I want to
know in your opinion you know as an
affirming Christian or as someone who's
a part of the community in whatever
regard what do you think most
non-affirming Christians Miss or get
wrong in the topic of gender and sexual
orientation where do you think that
disconnect lies okay so
um
yeah I said I I don't think it's a a
miss that has anything to do with Bible
knowledge
um the Miss is experiential and
relational it's easy to have like a
theory or perspective
on something
that you're not actually incorporating
in your life
um
and I don't mean like like a one-off
sort of
like engagement with somebody who's gay
or
um different than you like you just have
like that token moment or something like
that that doesn't count like I mean like
a real relationship
um
and that changes that changes you
so you're at that point I think if
you're in a really like real
relationship and you have certain
beliefs like traditional beliefs or
conservative beliefs you I think your
options are to
um ostracize ostracize them to some
degree
um or to fully love them and accept them
and I just cliche answer here is what
would you just do you know
um I don't think he'd be ostracizing
them and and putting boundaries and
limits on them
um
so yeah and another I want to kind of
also tell a little story
um
so
I went on a mission trip to India
it's been a while
um
and I was at a
at a orphanage
and so we're we're at this this
orphanage and the like the leaders of
the orphanages orphanage said hey we're
going to have some entertainment and
there's going to be some person that
comes come out that's going to dance for
you we're going to put on some music
and um
this is one I was a relatively new
Christian and I was kind of going
through that process of
you know
like wanting to really be
righteous and spiritual and
um
honoring God at everything that I did
right
and so
um this threw me for a loop so the the
person comes in
um
and they start dancing
um at first I'm like okay some ladies
coming out the answer she's resting
colorful clothing and this and that and
okay cool
um and then as I'm as I'm looking I'm
like huh
I think that might be a dude
um and then here I am in this Christian
setting with all these Christian leaders
and
um
I'm like that's a dude what's going on
right now like what is happening and
like I remember there was a moment
where I made eye contact with the person
and
something in me cringed because remember
this is old Gary like kind of like in
the early days of my Christian
journey I cringed and looked away
and never made eye contact again after
that
um
and I look back
on that version of myself
and I'm sad like that
I think God had
introduced me to that moment it had more
for me
and I rejected it
um
and so I think that's what people Miss
especially the people who have this
really narrow-minded view as they're
missing out on the beauty that God has
for them by having this narrow
perspective
um
that's really shallow and hurtful like I
can only imagine what that must have
felt like
to that person when you know when we
meet eye contact and I visibly cringed
and looked away
like I just that this makes me sick to
think about that now how I reacted
um
and I've done little things like that
you know throughout my process of coming
to a place of acceptance and affirmation
um
but I'm so glad that I am where I am
today because I like I said I look back
on that version of myself and I'm just
I'm sick it it
was not not cool not a not not a good
way to be and not a good friend not a
good human kind of mindset so anyways I
think the beautiful thing in that is
that you were able to recognize that and
where you are right now
um
because a lot of people don't a lot of
people live their lives continuing you
know to to do stuff like that and you
know my empathetic side is like I can
understand to an extent because I have
you know internalized homophobia as well
that I think anyone who's in my
community does it just was ingrained in
me so I think the most beautiful thing
is that you're like hey this happened
not cool what what can I do to make it
better next time so I appreciate you
sharing that
did you have anything Carrie yeah I'm
thankful for your courage to share that
because
that takes a lot
um
and what I think
is going on is fear I think the Devil's
Playground is fear
and when people have fear of the unknown
they just snap right back into their
indoctrination or anything that they've
been taught or heard or which is
probably part of where you were coming
from in that moment
but on the flip side of that is all it
takes is a little bit of action a little
bit of Bravery a little bit of courage
to just seek out some knowledge like
maybe they don't get it maybe they do
but it's just like what you experienced
I mean
oh wow so I can remember when I first
got on the fire department 95 that tells
my age
and I was the shortest female on Dallas
fire department and those guys were
freaking the crap out
because a girl was invading their space
I wasn't the first female on the
department but to be that short not be
able to reach a 12-foot ceiling but it's
the same kind of thing fear fear fear it
took a very long time to prove myself
and I think that's what happens with any
rejected community so to speak is
uh kind of like what you were sharing
it's it being internalized and we fear
of what's going to happen
uh as far as the communication or the
actions but after we prove ourselves
then people start to which is kind of
what happened with you God took you on a
journey and now it's like yeah I was
wrong all right but you know what we all
go through that if we all have the
courage to look within we've all done
that to some other human being it may
look a little bit different and that's
where we change the conversation is we
start to share bits of ourselves we
start to be vulnerable we start to be
like Gary and have the courage to share
like hey I did this and man I screwed up
but you
the devil
time's sake I wish we could talk more
and discuss more but I do want to thank
you both for Having the courage and
coming up here sharing your Journeys
with us just being able to speak on
behalf of the church and the members
that are part of this church so can
everyone give them a round of applause
thank you all so much
[Applause]
that time goes by so fast I'm like I
blinked and it's gone so
um again I am no brat but I'm gonna do
my best at
um welcoming welcoming all of you into
taking communion
um as Carrie mentioned she's been a part
of a church
um or churches I'm sure we all have
where
you know communion you have to be a part
a member a believer in Christ X Y and Z
to do that but here if you feel like you
are ready to take communion if you feel
like you're in the space to do so we
welcome you up and we want you to take
that and we're taking that with us now
just in case you haven't done it before
the way that we do it is you grab the
bread and the wine or the grape juice
and you just take it to wherever you
would like and
um you know take at your own time
um
the red is wine right okay because I
always take the white not a big wine
person red is wine uh White is grape
juice and the way we'll do it is first
row will come up just for sake of like
not congesting in the middle and we'll
go back
um and then we'll lead
Mindy will lead us in uh worship and
close this out so
this is the table not of the church but
of the Lord and it is made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have failed I'm sorry you have
tried to follow and you who have failed
come because it is the Lord who invites
you it is his will that those who want
him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we're going to close out with this
chorus and we'll keep it short so that
we can relieve our kids ministry or
workers
but one thing that stood out to me
through this entire series because this
has been a transition for me much like
what they shared just from what I grew
up believing and being told to where I
am now and I always come back to this
thing that Brett has said before
where are you filtering everything
through Jesus like that is our anchor
and so whatever new information has
potentially come your way
whether it whether it has been you know
jarring or maybe things that you've
heard a million times are we filtering
it through the life of Jesus he he is
our compass and what we see in him is
love
um just like they were sharing and
that's been so comforting to me and it's
disarmed me of some of the fear like
Carrie was talking about because I
couldn't agree more there's so much fear
um but through Jesus it says perfect
loves drives out fear so let's settle
into his love and um and interpret
everything in our lives through him
let him be our litmus test
so will you guys just sing this chorus
with us
um it says the way the truth the life I
believe you are
so we're just going to sing that
together a couple times
the way
[Music]
the truth
I believe you are the way
the truth yeah
[Music]
I believe
you're the truth in the life
[Music]
[Applause]
in the life
I believe
[Music]
let's sing it's a New Horizon
foreign
[Music]
it all come true
me
the light
I believe you are
[Music]
Harry and Gary for being vulnerable and
just sharing with all of us parts of
your lives I know that's
do but this place is just so comfortable
and so safe and I've never felt so seen
at a church and I'm just so grateful for
every single one of you and we can walk
in here and feel that connection with
each other that's genuine we don't have
a mask on we don't have to wear our
Sunday Best you know just to feel like
we are included so just appreciate all
of you if you are new welcome we do have
cards right outside of the door right
there on the tiny table if you wouldn't
mind filling one of those out we can
answer any questions we can thank you
for coming and just follow up with you
and uh let's see if you are in need of
prayer a hug support anything find me
after church find anyone and we'd love
to pray for you if you have more
questions for Carrie or Gary I'm sure
they'd love to answer those for you too
here at the table we are committed to
creating an inclusive christ-centered
community that touches lives and
generosity is obviously a huge key
component of that mission so if you're
willing to join us in this we want to
invite you to go to the tabletx.org
to support this work financially or you
can go to the tiny table over there and
your donation in the Box
I'd like to send you guys out with a
benediction if you don't mind you can
put your hands out you can stand sit
however you'd like to receive it
you are a child of God
you are a child of God this is true on
your best day and it is also true on
your worst day as you go into your week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you are and go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend those same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with be blessed have a great
week and we hope to see you here next
Sunday good night
[Music]
foreign
they can all come true
[Music]
true
foreign
[Music]